now to Jay Leno who's revealing just how  close to death he came after this  vintage steam car exploded and set him  on fire okay a little too much  you notice how I burned my hand okay  during an interview with TMZ from inside  the hospital where he could remain for  10 more days Jay says he has third  degree burns to his face and hands which  could require skin grafts so how did  this tragic accident unfold  okay he says he was fixing a fuel leak  on the vintage car when he was sprayed  with gasoline one Rogue spark then set  off the explosion Jay credits his friend  for saving his life by quickly jumping  in to smother the Flames trying to  believe a lot of these cars caught fire  isn't that I mean it's made of wood  during an episode of Jay Leno's Garage  he demonstrated just how precarious the  fuel system can be I don't want to burn  my check writing hand or the guys won't  be able to get paid  [Music]